[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for tuning in I would
really appreciate it if you'd hit the
Subscribe button I am in love with
today's episode today is with Corey
mcara he is a former monk he's an author
he wrote a book called stop waiting for
your life and he's the host of the
practicing human podcast I've been
following Corey on social media for a
long time he is has a away with words
written and verbal and today was a
really really great display of that um
of that verbal communication of Concepts
I was saying man if people will just
tune in and stay to the end of this like
if you want to be happier if you want if
you have a longing to know more to go
deeper to grow and evolve like this is
the episode of the way that it goes how
hard it can be how much patience you
need how much letting go is required how
much facing things you need and just
like you know he shares so nicely and I
add a few of my little stories in along
the way of examples of going through
some of these processes and like it's
just a beautiful beautiful episode of of
how to how to really invite change into
your life all I ever hope with this show
is that you listen and that there's
something that you take away from it you
can go oh aha like it's digestible and
useful these aren't just words these are
the show I just I do it cuz I love
interviewing people I love learning and
I just want to share like I just want to
plant some seeds with people and help
them grow into whatever the highest
calling version of yourself that you
want to be is and this episode's going
to help you do it so please enjoy if
you've been following me a while you
know that I've been drinking ag1 all
year no matter where I go or what I do
if I'm at the racetrack if I'm in Europe
for six weeks no matter what I'm
drinking ag1 every single morning when I
started drinking ag1 daily what I
noticed was that my gut health improved
I could eat so many different foods
without it bothering me my skin has
gotten better my hair is healthier so
many functions that everybody wants to
get better got better it's so awesome
and I've been bragging about it so much
that my friends and my family have also
started taking it and they love it as
well ag1 is the supplement that I trust
to support my body's daily needs and
that's why we' have been partners for so
long if you want to take ownership of
your health it starts with ag1 try ag1
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 plus five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink a1.com pretty intense that's drink
a1.com pretty intense check it out you
have a lot of courses I saw I'm a a
teacher at heart so I'm always creating
new stuff new Retreats new master
classes um I'm trying to figure out how
it all pieces together right now but
yeah I do have a lot of stuff what's the
most popular the shorter ones always get
the most signups I did I did one on
Cravings addictions and urges and we had
like several thousand people sign up for
that but the the more yeah I have one
called working with thoughts that's a
multi-week course that really goes deep
into working with the mind and that
one's been very fun popular Cravings
addictions urges cravings and addictions
are there different ones for men and
women that I was really trying to
explore like the
underlying uh I would call like the
underlying energetic of of a craving and
what's going on in the mind body system
and this feeling of like an
incompleteness until this is this is
gotten or achieved and where does that
stem from how do we work with that and
therefore it like kind of transcends and
includes all different cravings and
addictions so I really tried to get to
the heart of it rather than focusing so
much on the particular context and
content because it was such a popular
topic I really I'm going to redo that
one and go very deep into it well that's
kind of cool actually that's probably
super helpful for people because most of
these things is probably not anything
that anyone wants to say out loud and
you know it's like it's and they all
have their own unique things that are
their issues and it's always a root
right and that's kind of what I was
thinking about when I saw how many
different courses there was is you know
I'm I'm fascinated by psychology I love
figuring out how people work and even
into the more sort of quantum physics
realm of things can you trace things all
the way down to a single sort of point
that you should that you hit on that
goes when we pop this bubble it all
opens
up
yeah it's a fun question if if you were
to trace it all the way back as far down
it's of some feeling of trying to move
back toward wholeness and completeness
from the let from the spiritual
perspective this would be talking about
entering into the realm of Duality they
would call it which is like being a
human where I am me and you are you and
there's a sense of separateness and from
that pers perspective you've you've been
taken out of Oneness like a single
Consciousness and now are expressing
through individuality and there's just
this craving to get back to this longing
to get back to home and completeness and
therefore we're just constantly
searching for that in in our lives
through relationship through sex through
porn through anything that we might get
addicted to but anything that we're like
I need more of that what is that showing
you if you want
something what about the not whole is
that saying it shows us how we tend to
externalize this or the patterns and the
actions show us how we tend to
externalize this incompleteness this
void to something outside of us or the
path to filling it up to something
outside of us and there's Merit to that
I'm not someone who takes the
perspective of you know you should be
able to be completely content alone I
had that perspective when I was younger
and and that's that was one of the
motivations for doing deeper meditation
work and living in a monastery there was
just this like this feeling like I
should be able to be happy independent
of everything else and I saw that the
nature of being human is is to very much
be
interdependent I don't have any
delusions or grand ideas that that
people should be able to do that in
complete isolation but when it's
happening consciously when you're trying
to get filled up by something
unconsciously or someone or something
that's where we tend to get into uh
tricky territory because now we're we're
depending on the external environment
we're manipulating it or telling someone
to be a certain way for us or something
to be a certain way for us or needing
things to be arranged in a certain way
for us in order to feel okay rather than
maybe first just like acknowledging oo
something feels off here I have a desire
to feel connected and then leading
from that place in a more conscious
honest way when you said interdependent
like being interdependent and that is
more of our nature and I think it's so
cool that you took the chance and were
brave enough to go and be in silence as
a monk for six months so I'm very
curious about this and we're going to
follow this path all the way to your
wedding essentially because I have more
questions about as being dependent or
interdependent and do you mean that with
someone else when you say like we're not
meant to do this alone yeah I I mean it
in all the ways that we can be
interdependent I mean even just from
needing oxygen like dependent on our
environment friends connection yeah
family which can take so many different
forms but yeah being in Partnership as
well this human has evolved to have
different needs and I think denying that
or not including that in one spiritual
or Growth work uh is just like you then
end up getting an incomplete growth path
in this life or you end up spiritually
bypassing a bunch of stuff which is like
I don't need other people in order to
feel whole or complete and it's like not
actually true you're performing that
rather than deeply embodying it so
instead of asking you what you get with
Community what is it that you're lacking
without it I think might maybe the
better
question yeah and not to pathologize the
the longing I I think we can view that
longing like that feeling of
incompleteness or not being whole I
think we tend to pathologize that and
spiritual communities do this as well
personal growth communities that like
something's off or you're you're too
dependent on the external world like
yeah there may be some Merit to that
maybe you've very much set up your life
to need accomplishment other people sex
other people being a certain way for you
in order to be okay and happy and like
without that you have a void definitely
got to look at that cuz you can't you
can't live your life in a full way and
and not be impacting other people in a
negative way if you're completely
dependent on others that's like the
nature of codependence I need you to be
this way for me in order to be okay so
with that understood though like some
people then hear especially when they're
engaging in a spiritual journey where
they're like oh can I cultivate this
contentment independent of external
things then when you feel that longing
for connection or love or being in
Partnership or just not feeling empty we
can try to Med meditate our way around
that or out of it or or just pathologize
it with our own mind that something's
incomplete about us but the very nature
of being human is this almost like an
insatiable incompleteness it's just the
nature of being in Duality it's an
inherently partial experience of
aliveness for me to feel like I am me
and you to feel like you are you and
like never being able to merge or feel
Oneness so we're all trying to come back
to that and that
longing I I like the orientation I like
to take to that is like it's it's your
soul trying to come back to its
essential nature is one way you can put
it or you can just view if you're taking
more of a a secular approach it's just
the part of you that is inherently whole
and not caught up in ideas of I'm not
good enough or I need this in order to
be all right like that part of you it's
just trying to emerge more and more
deeply and so that longing to be with
another person or to be in Partnership
or even to fulfill a a craving if you
really look at the essence of it you
really get down to the Baseline
energetic of it it it has this feeling
of once I have that then I'll be okay
and
uh until you can have that conversation
with yourself about how you're relating
to the world around you you're going to
get caught up in kind of delusional
ideas of like I need a certain amount of
like a certain amount of money or a
certain amount of friends or certain
amount of success all of which is is
like true it's just not the complete
truth and when you go deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper you get to the
essential thing that's motivating all of
this which is just like this deep
feeling of of wanting to feel at home in
yourself and because we're in Duality
that longing gets externalized to
needing to have other people and things
you're using the word inherent and I get
very curious about what it is about the
nature of this reality and ask many
questions about like is this just part
of our experience is there no escaping
this is this just inherent with our
experience and we have to learn how to
deal with it and accept it so the
question is is that this Duality this
longing being inherent meaning to me
what you're saying is is this was
forever this is part of being human and
so is that what you're saying and is it
a matter of just getting closer and
closer and closer to sort of being at
peace with things as opposed to ever
feeling like maybe you'll never be
complete because in
this three-dimensional Realm
of
Duality there is a visual
separateness you can't ever escape this
inherent nature on this
plane the more I make permission for all
layers of my myself to be felt and
experienced without making them wrong or
denying them like everything that comes
with being a human jealousy
impatience craving longing wanting love
needing to be boundaried wanting my
alone time the more I I make space for
all of that the more I see it's just the
the
inherent where when I use that word like
what's inherent to being in a mind body
is the impermanent nature of experience
and and it is to have all of these needs
that constantly want to be uh
fulfilled and the constant feeling of
once that's okay or once this tension is
resolved then I'll be able to relax and
complete and it so it just shows up with
everything from the moment you wake up
and you're like oh I'm groggy and then
it's like oh have coffee and then
there's a feeling attaching coffee is
going to be the thing and then just cut
out was the last of my uh stimulants to
cut out a few months ago and I wanted to
see what happens if I really just like
take away the last of my painkillers the
first thing was like how much I don't
enjoy doing mundane work that if I just
if I just stimulate and put on some cool
music I'm like yeah totally I can write
a bunch of Instagram posts and do a
bunch of emails and it's so easy to
judge people from that especially in
like the hustle culture if you look at
so many of the people hustling and
putting and like putting the grind
mentality out into the social media
world or just like you gota you got to
work hard you got to do like the amount
of compensation through exogenous
whatever it's like through the roof I
heard some scientist talking about the
neuroprotective benefits of nicotine a
couple of years ago so I I'm always
curious in the optimizing department and
so I tried it and um I was using very
small doses and it's delightful uh it's
not this huge high but it's just like
gives you a little buzz that makes you
want to do stuff we have a great quote I
I wrote down a whole bunch of quotes so
I'm probably going to end up I was I I'm
going to plug them in where they're
applicable but it it it makes me think
of this being proud of yourself for
taking a break despite others thinking
you're lazy because you know that
sometimes it's actually way harder to
slow down than simply keep grinding I
love that yeah I think that's applicable
here as well I've needed to give myself
a lot of permission for a certain kind
of unwinding in the last six months so
so I cut out that nicotine and then I
was just like oh wow I was really
buoying myself into a certain mood and a
certain like desire to work through this
substance and you can make the argument
like who cares why not just do that
forever for whatever reason uh I was
just curious what it's like to do that
without and then I cut out caffeine as
well and I F I did not have the same
level of of motivation and I needed to
give myself like a long period like
permission to unwind for a period of
time to want to let my adrenals reset
but just to see like how much cultural
pressure and influence there is to be
performing at a a certain level
consistently especially when you're
running I think that
that um points to another quote that I
think is applicable here which is
long-term energy comes from alignment
not anxiety if you want consistent
motivation make sure you're connected to
your whole self not just a childhood
idea of what you need to achieve in
order to feel less empty like cuz one of
the things that I've experienced in my
life by the way I just have to say
you're a wonderful writer which which is
why I've you I wanted to use a bunch of
your words today because you really put
things in a very simple digestible way
so well done um yeah um but it it
reminds me of one of the lessons that I
learned in my life which was that the
things that are meant for me give me
energy and what's not meant for me takes
energy from me and we're not talking
about the same amount of energy
expenditure for either at all like I go
do 30 minutes of like the most boring
questions some reporter has to ask me or
I could do I could be outside gardening
I could be outside gardening for three
hours and like I get done and I'm
bubbling and excited but when I took 30
minutes to answer some questions sitting
on a chair and I feel Zapped from it and
I it was such good it was it's such good
body feedback on what's meant for you so
like with the knowledge that the mundane
things do not like drain you like how do
you adjust your life how does someone
take this put this into action and go
okay these things totally drain me now
what do you do sometimes your life just
completely falls
apart it it all so I I say that a bit
factitiously sometimes that that can
happen but I I caution against people
doing some version of that where you
have this wakeup moment and you're like
oh man everything that I've been doing
is just completely off I've built my my
life on a foundation of abandoning
myself moment after moment after moment
saying yeah this is good enough or I'm
doing this because I'm going to get some
that'll make me happier in the future
and it's just like lots of moments where
you had the opportunity to align and
then you compensated a little bit it's
yeah just building a like a Jenga
Foundation that eventually you get to
the top and it's so wobbly and the whole
thing collapses what what can happen
when you have that realization is many
people go oh my gosh I'm doing
everything wrong and then like I need to
blow it all up in order to have my
Foundation again or in order to get back
into
alignment that that is actually the ego
masquerading as wisdom it's another end
of the Continuum of like I'm just going
to passively resign to my life to I'm G
to like completely destroy everything
and it doesn't feel like destroying but
it's like I'm going to I'm going to
completely throw it all away so I could
start fresh and go like you know have a
bar in Maui I just so I'm GNA get
divorce leave the kids and and that's
also one thing that scares a lot of
people from being an honest conversation
with themselves where they they fear
that they're going to get in touch with
something that indicates that what
they've been doing um is not quite right
or is out of alignment and the
implications of being being an honest
conversation with yourself just feel too
massive what if this is the wrong
partnership you know what if I like I'm
not actually fulfilled in my work and
like what's this going to mean for my
kids for my connection with others for
how I make money and um and that's where
I really encourage people to slow down
to recognize that just cuz something is
coming through doesn't mean that the
wise thing to do is to blow it all up or
even that you should blow it up or even
like if you're in a partnership that
doesn't feel quite right just cuz that's
coming through and you have the
recognition that the last 30 years have
like you've been abandoning yourself in
the relationship or vice versa doesn't
even mean that that relationship has to
end all you know right now is what's
arising what's happening is not working
in this moment and that's where if you
let that right just treat that as like a
soft Whisper of wisdom moving through
you and and it often has that quality
it's it's um it's just like something's
not right something's not right uh and
it feels off you you start listening to
that like that you just want to protect
it's very precious it's it's like I
would call it like the quiet Whispers of
the soul the ego the ego tends to be
more uh loud noisy yeah excited Lusty
this person's going to be everything for
me I can't wait to be I finally found my
partner the person that's going to make
me complete right that's the ego that's
like a childhood wound externalizing its
wholeness onto something or someone else
and so that like lust has that feeling
but the ego also has this defensive
thing of just like oh my God for the
first time I'm seeing that everything
everyone around me it's ruining my life
and so I have to destroy it that's also
like a childlike
uh get me away and make me safe so all
you know and this is where you want to
go slow is just like something's moving
through that's saying it's not quite
right I have a longing for something
else something deeper more connection to
be seen to go slow or to be able to work
harder whatever it might be and that's
the the first step for people in those
positions I I just say just your only
job right now is just to stay in quiet
conversation with that part of you you
don't need to act on it you don't even
know what it means yet all you know is
that there's something coming through
with the current arrangement of your
life and it's like okay and it and truly
if if you just stay in conversation with
that part of you if you just keep
listening to it giving it space giving
it permission that you can make the
argument that that can take you all the
way throughout the rest of your life if
you just stay present to it because it
it will eventually inform action you may
be scared of it for a while you may
override it but if you stay presence has
this pressure cooker type nature to it
and if you shine presence onto the
reality of what's here without numbing
it or suffocating it eventually that
that voice of you could call it like
truth but like let's just say like the
whisper deeper inside of you it's going
to get louder and more prominent and
it's going it's going to move its way
through your conditioning and when I say
conditioning those are all of your ideas
beliefs that you've developed over a
course of a lifetime from a very early
age about who you need to be and what
you need to do in order to get safety
love and
praise usually all of that is
suffocating these softer Whispers in our
being and it's these moments where the
system just gets so overwhelmed that it
kind of kind of like let's go and you're
brought to our your knees that something
actually has the space to come through
and it it's those softer Whispers that
end up
arising if you now shine the spotlight
on that and you start protecting it and
holding it as precious and listening to
it it will get louder not in a noisy
kind of way or a violent kind of way but
it will get Amplified in the system and
it will become stronger and it will
start to take on a life of its own where
then abandoning yourself or doing
something that's not in alignment or
doing something that's
codependent you you will hit points
where it's like I literally can't do
this anymore I just have so much one I
have so much compassion for anyone who's
walking that path anyone who finds
themsel in this place in life where it's
like I have I have built something that
I now realize is built on years or
Decades of maybe being disconnected from
myself and something things coming
through and I am so terrified of what it
means to follow that and I don't even
know where to start I I have so much
compassion for for someone who even just
has the willingness to acknowledge that
and I more than anything in this life
100% back a person's right to that
journey to taking the steps down that
journey and and and following where
those where that thread takes them where
the unwind when you follow that thread
like what unwinds and what patterns have
to be seen and burnt up um that are no
longer serving to you that's it's
basically my sole intention in my work
and in my personal life uh of doing that
I I think it is the most sacred work you
can do as a human being and and so I
will back anyone 100% in that Journey
always and I also know how brutally hard
it can be and how much might need to
fall away as you do that and that's why
I say go slow you don't have to blow it
up this can take this can take place
over the the next 30 Years 20 years but
trust trust the unfolding through you
staying in conversation with that new
place in you because it's precious and
it it will give you
answers what to do next you should
probably mik drop it at this point
so true and it's just like so many
things that voice is so so subtle it's
usually short too sort of the Soul's
messages are usually very short in my
experience they're like you know or like
there'll be a couple of words or maybe a
sentence at the most but it's just like
it's just this repeating theme and
you're like okay okay and that slow part
I've only come in the
last year or two to really be better at
that but the slow part is because in my
experience the path is not quite laid
out yet like like if you go slow enough
the right opportunities just fall into
place like it should it ends up becoming
obvious not easy not effortless but like
you don't have to effort for the right
answer it kind of becomes obvious and
then you know what you need to do next
yeah does that make sense does that
resonate too totally the obviousness of
it like in in the
beginning and I think you're alluding to
this as well it's not obvious I mean
there's so much noise in the system
scary yeah it's just like like holy
what am I gonna do it's a mess in there
and how do I parse anxiety from
intuition and it's and so I would also
say to anyone on that Journey who's like
so frustrated with what it means to be
human or even like you might get mad at
me hearing this like well how do you do
it I would just say like start by
staying staying with the frustration and
and know that you are so not alone in in
in feeling how complicated and messy
this is and and usually the anger that
extends from that is just like an
unwillingness or or not wanting to feel
the discomfort of it but if if you just
first meet that and hop in and and trust
that there's a journey
here I can say from my own experience it
it is potentially and I would argue 100%
that it is the most valuable Journey you
take in your lifetime because it's your
journey with yourself and everything
extends from that and I I just I also
want to just Define some language
because we're we're using words like
soul and ego and that can feel like it
has like an overl spiritual or religious
connotation I use the word Soul um
mainly because it it seems to be
something a lot of people uh it's a word
that's more used in our society to talk
about this deeper place within us but if
you want more of a psychological lens
for anyone listening to this who like I
I always filter everything through 10y
year younger Corey when I was starting
out with this stuff and I just rolled my
eyes so the psychological I think the
best psychological way to think about
this is um there's a a therapeutic
practice called internal family systems
created by Richard Schwarz and you know
he was working with people who just were
in deep pain suicidal just like really
into depths and what he found is that
you know he's the founder of of Parts
work this idea that there are all these
different um facets of who we are that
take on different roles to defend us to
protect us to manage the system to keep
us safe uh and it's really beautiful
because I think we can all identify with
that and and a great book for that is no
bad parts by Richard Schwarz but anyway
the thing I have found Most Fascinating
with his work is that like across all
the people he's worked with oneon-one
thousands of people in all different
contexts right and all these different
parts that emerge that cause people to
do an infinite number of different kinds
of things even though they might have
similar patterns behind all of those
protective mechanisms for every single
person he found there was something
consistent that served as the backdrop
for all of it and this is what he called
self and we could say it with like a
capital S and it was this like space
that wasn't trying to overly protect you
or manage you or like sabotage your life
it was just sort of still in the
background and it had there were these
cons consistent qualities of it of being
compassionate courageous confident
calm and I think I I when I first came
across that in psychological literature
I just thought it was super interesting
because if you go into all these
different spiritual Traditions they'll
talk about it in different ways as
Spirit as Soul or as awareness um and a
lot of Buddhist practice they talk about
just this backdrop of awareness that's
that's witnessing everything that's
happening but here he came to that
himself through his own work with people
that there's something
consistent for everyone and what is it
like to actually lead your life from
that place rather than from a protective
part that emerged when you were three
year three years old that said if anyone
gets too close um we end up losing love
at some point so don't let anyone come
in and now any future relationship we
kind of have these knives that protect
anyone from getting close to us right
that would be a part but when you drop
beneath that and you get still enough to
feel the space behind it there's
something else and I think when we often
think of like leading our lives from our
best self what most of us are pointing
to is that other place within us so when
you hear me use words like Soul or ego
Soul I'm basically referring to that
space behind it all self and ego I'm
referring to the parts that get
developed in order to protect
the different needs and desires of of
your human do you know who Teal Swan is
yes yeah um well we're friends and she
did a little Parts work with me one day
for about five hours
wow so we went into a couple of
different aspects of me one was of
course like the so basically she was
kind of identifying there's this sort of
like guardedness like there's like a
there's something very tough there and
like what is that and so she told me to
go to a spot in the room that
represented that aspect of me and so I
like sat on the arm of the couch and
like stood there and I was like you know
very like poised and um I went into this
aspect of me like you have to fully
embody it which isn't that hard actually
and I got into that and that like my
voice was different and my stance my
words my everything I had to say had to
do with like protection but for me like
yes the self is back there but the self
is being hidden behind someone
protecting me from something that has
happened right so I needed to so I had
to put up a big front because I was
young and exposed to a lot of things and
I needed to be tough and strong and I
couldn't let anyone in and I had to be I
just had to be very vigilant for my
space and my energy because I had so
much to do and to do it so fast to do it
so young and I was very protective of
myself and so I would I would only like
really resonate with other sharks as we
call called them like she's like yeah
but yeah maybe there are some decent
sharks but maybe you like want a koala
bear you know like maybe you want like
there are other animals out there like
you don't have to just allow sharks in
and so it was defeating the purpose even
because all I was really letting in were
other equal like really tough people and
so and then the and then I flipped over
to the opposite side of that which was
and then I took another spot in the room
and I like laid out on the couch and I
kind of curled up and then I just
started crying
and like the other side of me was super
chill and calm and relaxed and I just
like want to cuddle and so like that
part of me was then able to be seen and
so then of course for both of them you
talk about like what is it there for
what role is it playing what is it
protecting you from what you know
basically what's the story you're
telling yourself and it was fascinating
because I was so two totally different
people it was really interesting that's
a great a great story I could feel all
the different
layers of it and my own personal
experience of it have you done Parts
work like like does that like was
your yeah I I've done it in different
ways um I think what's been most
striking to me about Parts work or or
the experience of these parts is how
fractured they can be I mean that's kind
of the the nature of a part that it's
fractured from something else or it's
separate but fractured in the sense of
like when a certain part comes online in
a particular context it almost it can
feel impossible to access the worldview
or the emotions of of the other part or
of self which is why you know you when
maybe you feel calm or relaxed in a
particular context you're like okay I
know I need to do this I I know I need
to break up or I know I need to get out
of this job or I know I need to take
this risk and then when you get closer
to it and something gets activated and
the part comes online to protect you
then it's like it's almost like you
can't even you can't even access the
part of you that knew you needed to do
it that's like almost like an anxiety
aspect to it because like anxiety being
that thing you can't get out of like
you're just stuck in it you're totally
right about that yeah and I just found
that super fascinating and it really
characterized I mean my relationship
Journey getting to where I am now with
my partner Brianna where we just got
married a few weeks ago but the first
five years were just characterized by
Deep not knowing and being like there
was some like ineffable force that like
pulled us together and then a lot of
stuff that needed to be worked out that
was
preventing actually feeling like the
foundation of of Truth and our
connection and lots of parts that each
of us activated in the other that made
it seem like maybe this isn't right but
I I remember at at various points in the
relationship it was very clear that we
would need to take space and I'm very
clear in that in us getting to the point
that we eventually did that like we
needed to come in and out of
partnership uh for a while and there
were times where like I I knew when I
was still and calm that I was like all
right we need we need space it would
sometimes come up as um this needs to
end and my ego would be terrified
because it didn't feel right that the
relationship was to be over when I
really checked I was like is this like
the quiet part of you was like we need
space but then the louder part was like
oh my God that's that's dangerous and
yeah what are the implications of that
and that's what the ego is in
conditioning is concerned with more of
like a linear relationship to your life
and to again to get like more spiritual
like wisdom typically comes on a
vertical plane and the ego works on a
horizontal so the vertical plane is just
like the truth of what's happening right
now is all that we have the horizontal
plane is like what is this going to mean
in the context of past present and
future and am I going to be alone
forever you and that is just so beyond
your pay grade to be able to know what
any moment of knowing actually means and
I I could even make the argument that
the whole like what the spiritual
journey looks like in the three
dimensional world is just learning to
trust those moments of knowing a as
they're unfolding
but for for me I would get these moments
of knowing and then it would be hijacked
by my ego mind and it's like well if you
do that you're going to be alone and you
love this person and so I would have
those I would hold on to them of just
like all right we need to do this we
need to we need to take space and I
would literally be like walking up to
the door to have this
conversation and my heart would start
racing my mind would start going and I
would they call it blending in internal
family systems where the part mask
erades itself as the wise self and it
feels like the most true thing and then
I would be like wait what am I what am I
doing it doesn't make sense to do this
and and I couldn't I couldn't access
that deeper knowing again and it was
just so
interesting to see how some of these
parts that have particular World Views
and ways of Defending you and don't want
you to be hurt or want you to get
certain things when they come online um
it's very difficult to to feel anything
else uh or to to reconnect to the truer
thing and and that's why it's important
to there's a bunch of practices you can
do with this and a lot of them are in
that book no bad parts but even just
doing visualization practices where you
give a visual image to the part maybe a
younger part that's protecting you
that's saying we can't do this and then
giving a visual image to the self that's
saying like that knows that we should do
this and you know for me sometimes that
part looks like a 5-year-old version of
Corey and I'll imagine that in front of
me maybe sitting in a chair and then the
wiser part will like look like Gandalf
from Lord of the Rings or something and
and by putting some visual form onto
these internal energies it allows you to
be in relationship to them rather than
this like messy soup
internally and then you can have them
communicating to each other and and I
would just I would have and I would
really keep it as simple as like as the
the self part you could call that a
guide to communicate with the scared
part and ask like what are you concerns
going to happen and then the scared part
can ask the the self like how might you
be able to help me with this are we
going to be okay and just having them
com uh Converse as two separate entities
helps with that un blending process so
that there's more space in these moments
where you're trying to make decisions to
guide your life from a deeper place
rather than it just feeling like one
mess of noise yes I forgot about that
part but it also helps you feel it's
almost like doing inner child work um
being call it the self higher self like
I look at them all as very very much the
same but when I was working on
boundaries I had to look at it like for
her because then I could do it but if it
was for me it was too messy or I'd
deprioritize but like if you were to say
is this scenario okay for like a little
girl to experience you go oh hell no and
so you get a better gauge because it's
it's like exacerbating the reality which
is it is separate from you the self is
behind it all so like you get to be the
Observer then watching this Dynamic you
go oh oh that's what's going on and it
helps crystallize things a bit more big
time yeah and yeah the first moments of
seeing that distinction between a part
and and to self is just a very uh I mean
it could be life transforming but it's
it's quite liberating as well it g it
provides hope too and it gets you in
touch with the part of you that across
the board every person has this
experience it just feels more you and
and true one of the things that I want
to speak to a little bit is because
people listening probably are very
interested in this they're interested in
self-development um they've probably
been through through quite a bit or
maybe they're on the
precipitate and the person they're with
isn't and they want to know how can they
like get in there and help them and so
I'm very curious like the word truth has
come up and one of the things I hadn't
talked about this in a while in a little
while but the the idea
that people don't want to know the truth
because it
essentially when you start to know the
truth about anything um but especially
the fundamentals like if you get start
start to get the exposure to the
fundamentals of the truth of religion
maybe or um politics or your parent
whatever whatever it may be just the
truth that's the building blocks of your
entire life and so people my theory
being that people avoid that because
they subconsciously know that when they
deal with any one of those that it
essentially like the House of Cards
Falls because the the foundation is that
and it's built upon it and so it might
imply some things that you mentioned it
might imply your job changes your
relationships change your friends change
where you live might change and and I
think that people might subconsciously
know that and so I'm happy for you to
speak to that but I'm I'm also just
generally curious if this is something
that I feel like I've had to also just
sort of make peace with is
that I just don't know if everyone is
meant to
evolve like some people get to the edge
and they go
no it's not for me and they turn back
and like how do we love someone through
that and do you think that's even true
do you think that we're all meant to
evolve or is are some Souls here just to
maybe this is the cruise control life
you know
yeah I definitely think that's true that
people you could call it they have a
different uh Dharma or Karma like
there's no craving to grow they don't
want to learn they don't want to know
they don't they they're really really
happy in their bubble they're happy in
their little town they just don't want
to they don't crave getting out they
don't crave the
unknown and if we
take a slightly more
like unified approach that let's just
say at the heart of it we are all coming
from the same thing and that same thing
we'll just call it like Consciousness
Oneness in this reality is expressing
itself through individual
form from that perspective it's less
that like oh I'm I'm evolve I'm evolving
and I'm growing and you're not and more
that this thing is just expressing
itself through the fractal of of this
plane in all different ways in the same
way that like a beehive all the
different bees are like working in
Unison in different ways to support
something or even just like my own
individual body it's like my thumb does
a lot of work but my pinky doesn't do as
much or like my little facial hair over
here is really not doing as much as my
hands are doing or my heart and I
wouldn't necessarily say that oh my
heart just really is a lot more evolved
than this piece of facial hair here it's
all kind of like playing a different
role in the
system I think it's it's one approach we
can take to like how we're all
collectively growing in duality and
we're just playing like different roles
for it all and and with that said like
we can have we can have a ton of space
for other people's Journeys and ton of
compassion and ton of love for like that
and if we also feel that that's not
working for us being in relationship to
them regardless of what the relationship
looks like then we're each honoring that
within ourselves and if if our voice is
particularly louder than another person
like this is important then yeah then
then we're in a conundrum it's it's the
conundrum of of self-awareness where
it's just like yeah there there is to
not want to see so clearly and to not
want to grow as much like life can be
easier in a certain way you suffer in
other ways because of that but to be uh
more asleep or even just let's put it in
a positive frame to be more okay with
just the way things
are can be a lot easier and and for
those who
maybe in this particular lifetime just
have this deep desire to see more
clearly for whatever reason I mean you
can't even take credit for that where
can I I don't know where in my
experience I could actually take credit
for how that developed in in me versus
like my brother or my sister and we all
have it in different ways we had a
similar upbringing we were given some
genetic found foundation and then a
fairly similar social uh upbringing and
we Express in different ways I I don't
know at what point I can
say that like that I installed the
desire to go live in a monastery and see
more clearly in a way that I could like
actually take credit for any of it it
all just moved through me in a
particular way that yeah for whatever
reason when it did move through me I
said this is what I want to follow but
even that like if I had a more traumatic
upbringing then I might have felt like I
don't want to go into that and and why I
someone would have a more traumatic
upbringing than me again is just like
too beyond my pay grade to to discern or
to take any credit for one over the
other so the what's the point I'm trying
to make with this well I wonder let me
ask a question so since I really firmly
believe that everyone is a mirror for us
and that I don't see things as they are
I see things as I am and so if I'm with
someone and I want them to grow and
evolve and change let's
say it's actually probably showing me me
in a way that I need to figure out what
do I need to just accept about myself
what is it that I'm striving so hard for
where can I have more peace and
acceptance than myself and it's go it
reminds me of one of the um one of your
lessons from you have I think 30 3 or 31
lessons that you like took away from
being a monk this is number eight what
you hate most in others is usually what
you hate most in yourself and so this
sort of idea of like what we judge in
someone else usually is very much A lot
of times what we deny within ourselves
so like if we're judging that someone
doesn't want to change and grow and
evolve then we're probably denying
oursel the ability to sit still for a
moment and just be okay like you don't
always have to seek you can just enjoy
the trees and the dogs and the kids and
the whatever like it's like what part of
you can't sit still so it's probably
more of I'm processing out loud right
now it's probably more of that does that
does that do you think so like what are
your thoughts on that big time um that
that one point when that post made its
rounds on social media um it reached Far
Corners of the internet uh the whatever
it was the 31 lessons from living as a
monk that one point was the most
provocative one for people really oh
yeah yeah that you would you uh hate in
others is often what you hate in
yourself and it it's it's not an
absolute thing you can make an argument
for an absolute version of it but people
would often push back on that by saying
so like if if I hate seeing War does
that mean that I like hate that in
myself or that that's just purely a
reflection of something that's not
integrated in me rather than like
something really being off
externally I I think even with something
like that if we don't have space for our
own capacity for let's just say violence
then when we see it externally we're
gonna we're going to take an even
stronger stance of bad bad bad and
there's a difference between doing that
unconsciously when a part isn't
integrated and we haven't made space for
like our own capacity for the things
things that we hate outside of us that
that those seeds are also within us
maybe just not watered um it's it's one
thing to do that
unconsciously uh and it's another thing
to do it to do it consciously where it's
just like yeah I see that I have the
potential to be doing what this other
person is doing and at the same time
it's not right and like this is my
stance that I'm going to take in
relationship to it that I would say is
like embodied activism versus
disembodied activism where we're kind of
just performing the sound bites of what
you're supposed to say or like a
performative idea of what you should do
because everyone else is saying what you
should do so going back to the the main
point here is like yeah people are
hugely a mirror for us and if we have a
real strong particular charge in
relationship to another person it
usually does represent something that um
we haven't made space for in ourselves
and I think your example was was great I
do see this you know because I do a lot
of work with Stillness and meditation
and the value of that even though that's
not the whole game of what I teach but I
I see it a lot with people who do very
intense Sports um they have a lot of
judgment I'm sure you're familiar in
this
world right and and that's probably why
you named it as an example as well
because you I'm I'm sure you've seen it
other people or seen it in yourself
that's number one for me lazy I I judge
just judge lazy people so much because I
didn't even I literally rest was not on
my vocabulary like rest was like it's
just called lazy like oh I'm just being
lazy today like no I'm resting or I'm
recovering or whatever like it was not
in my vocabulary so I judged them
because I absolutely denied that in
myself I I just want to give you props
for this because it's so huge for people
to hear this from someone who's actually
gone through it to be able to be able to
name it in the way that you're naming it
um to do it in an embodied way like you
saw you saw the part clearly and then
now on the other side and you could also
see the value of it in your life and
still engage in the part of you that
likes to work hard uh and intense but it
has space rather than being the defining
characteristic of you and yeah and I I
had that as well not as strong but it
was I mean my life was very much
characterized by intensity and I found a
monastery that was arguably one of the
most intense monasteries and I was just
like I want to cry you know 14 hours a
day of meditation in silence not eating
much like not sleeping much on a plank
of wood it's just like I want it to be
hard and so you could see how you could
you could bring all of your conditioning
into the practices that are designed to
unwind your conditioning and sure
exactly it's Sneaky man it's very sneaky
very sneaky what were some coping did
you have like were there some things in
the beginning that you ended up
realizing you were using as like slight
coping mechanisms for this for yourself
oh yeah I mean at least in this context
like using using intensity to try to get
me
to wholeness I mean my my orientation
which served me to an extent was like if
anyone's going to get enlightened at
this Monastery it's going to be me so
um it's a it's a very interesting
approach to take when you're trying to
see beyond like the individual nature of
yourself and you're taking a very
self-oriented approach so I mean I I'm
gonna win this exactly I am going to win
meditating I'm gonna get enlightened
faster than anyone else so I and it was
it was a good I needed to play out that
pattern because if if I were to if
someone were to tell me to just like
calm down a bit and to perform calming
down rather than really seeing clearly
that I needed to calm down it wouldn't
have landed like I needed to see very
clearly that this pattern was not
serving me because up up until that
point in my life I think I just had
positive reinforcement for that pattern
oh sure and and so I would push myself
like we were waking up at 3:00 a.m. we'd
go to bed around 900 p.m but I was
cutting my sleep down to a couple hours
a night I was meditating up to 18 hours
a day and and I would even there was
such an emphasis on maintaining momentto
moment continuity of presence that I was
trying to eliminate any single moment of
the Mind wandering and the way I would
do that was when I was meditating
focusing on my breath I would imagine a
string going from my awareness to my
breath and as long as those were
connected then that string was tight now
connected to that string was a pulley
system that had a a tray hanging under
it with my whole family sitting on top
of that tray and underneath them was a
bed of lava so if I were to not be aware
of my breath for a moment string would
snip and then I'd kill my family right
so like I would use and it was you
couldn't even tell anyone that you were
thinking that because you were in a
stent Monastery and honestly I don't
even my teacher might have approved of
it honestly and it it it served like I
don't want to completely throw it out
because it was it was useful to an
extent but the main thing that it was
useful for was just highlighting the
intensity of this pattern and showing me
that I wasn't actually getting what I
wanted from that it was it was really
while my concentration was getting
deeper and I was developing a certain
level of awareness I was also developing
a certain background feeling of of
really being wound up and it was only
through like following that through to
completion and being like I literally
can't do this anymore and then on the
heels of that I can't do this anymore
something just softened and I was like
oh I can actually just be in my
experience aware of my thoughts aware of
my emotions and my Sensations just here
without straining and then mind wanders
and I could just I can hold the Mind
wandering with love and grace and then
come back and and I I was able to see
that there was a different way to be in
relationship to my whole experience and
I I give that background
because I I think for a lot of people
you might you you're aware of patterns
that you might be doing but there's
still there's still a sense
of feeling like it's serving you in a
really positive way you haven't yet seen
maybe what other people are telling you
they
see and I had a lot of good teachers
along the way especially after I got
back from the monastery who really gave
me me permission to follow these
patterns like certain patterns I I
remember I remember I had a lot of
complic a complicated relationship to
money after living as a monk because all
of that was based on donation and it's a
lot of complicated stuff in spirituality
around money and um and I had one
teacher who spent even more time in the
same Monastery that I was at I remember
telling her just like I feel like I want
to make money but I shouldn't want to
make money she was like why don't you
just like let yourself try to become a
billionaire I was like wait what and she
was like yeah if that's like if that's a
pattern that needs to play it out well
you're not going to play it out by
telling yourself that you shouldn't want
it now you're just that's spiritual
bypassing like I shouldn't want this so
I'm going to be someone who doesn't want
it but what do you have then you have a
mind that's telling you something but
deep down like still like this
underlying belief that if I did have
that then I would be okay sometimes that
pattern needs to be played out and seen
through clearly and vividly before the
system actually lets go of it
energetically and then on the other side
of it you have real space and Clarity so
for anyone that's in that like
unfortunately you might have to
sometimes run yourself into the ground
before you realize like truly and
clearly that that's no longer serving
you and then usually on the other side
of it you have a complete holistic
perspective of it and you never you
never throw it out entirely like that
you can always see the Merit of what
that served for you and what it may
still serve for you but also see where
it's been incomplete beautiful it's it's
it's we think of um for me one of my
favorite books is The Alchemist and the
me and the lesson to me in The Alchemist
is that you know the boy got there was
point A to point B and presumably when
you get to the end of the book it seems
like oh it was just kind of right there
and like things were simple but but it's
like it's you can't just go to B you
can't just take a step and go to B you
actually actually have to go this
roundabout way all the way and that
actually is the fastest way that is the
only way and it's the only way and we
think of all these tribulations and
trials and adversity and and and we
think of it as like wasted time or it's
they're all part of the process and we
all have a different point that we have
to get to before something really sinks
in and that's the that's just life
sometimes it's just you have to let
things run their course and even though
you think it should been easy and you're
like oh if I'd have just done that you
have to go through the whole thing yeah
and I just I can't overstate the
importance of that enough if you bypass
any step of what's in front of you
you're going to have to come back to it
at some point in the future it's there's
just a there's an energetic law to it I
don't understand why I can make an an
argument for it but I mean there were
things that I did in my child like
little dumb things that were unethical
like when I was 7 years old and my mom
asked us to take out the trash me and my
brother and I like fell on the ground
and pretend I got injured so that I
wouldn't have to do it and he did it it
just like something dumb that a child
would do or this child at least that
came roaring through when I was in the
monastery when when my heart was opening
it was like it was just incinerating
anything that has ever been out of
alignment in my life and I just like I
had to feel deep pain a betrayal of
myself of like feelings of not being a
good person and and so and and I always
see it um just like anything that I Sid
step or don't want to feel fully I have
to make up for it at some point in the
future unless I'm going to just keep
suppressing you can keep suppressing
until the end of your life but then you
pay for it in other ways if you want to
really continue to be open and honest
you can't bypass that that process I
think Jordan Peterson says that
absolutely nothing is free you get away
with absolutely nothing in your life you
get and like the implications of that
feel heavy but it should be inspiring to
to live in integrity and figure things
out because again he's like in his he
said I never I've never seen anyone get
away with anything like doing a tally on
my life right now I'm like oh what do I
what what what's left to What's Left to
balance out the the the
scales I want to read this quote uh if
you ask how I can make it through if I
if you ask how if you ask how I can make
it through this you'll get answers to
help you survive if you ask how this
experience might bring out the best in
me you'll get answers that help you
thrive and it makes me think about you
know the nature of the
universe and also just like orienting
with our perception I believe the
perceptions reality and so how do we how
do we shape that like what are the what
are these laws of the universe that we
can use in our
favor yeah right well I I think
perception is uh is a way that we can
Channel our life force which or or just
our energy which I would argue that the
mind in general is a is a way that we
Channel our energy and so this in this
case this is a you know using the role
of of questioning to generate different
answers and and open up different things
in you and so if if like yeah you're
going through something difficult and
you just ask the question how am I going
to make it through this well then like
at best you'll get something that maybe
helps you make it through it because the
the mind is a a question answering
machine but if you ask something
different like how might this bring out
the best in me or what might this be
inviting me to touch or to feel or to
see
well now now you're actually letting
this experience trouble you into a
deeper conversation with your soul and
you know if your orientation is to see
more in this life then that framing with
the mind won't just take you into
survival but it'll take you into opening
and descending and expanding yeah yeah I
I find that I find that when like I'm
happier it changeed my perception than
your world just keeps changing you know
like you know it's just kind of as a
ripple effect yes yeah big time and yeah
and then you get these upward spirals
that Barbara Frederickson out of UNCC
Chapel Hill talks about where like the
the role of a positive emotion can then
cause you to think differently and more
positively and feel better about
yourself which then might cause you to
go reach out to a friend and then that
feels good and then you feel more
inspiring go like I'm going to go take
that dance class that I was thinking I
couldn't do and then that leads to more
movement in the body you get more
positive emotion and you just get these
like upward spirals in your life that
can start from just single moments like
this another quote that's similar is of
yours is uh an interesting thing happens
when you start to respect yourself you
become much more sensitive to other
people not respecting you and much less
tolerant of it yeah yeah this is another
one that people have found or it can be
a little controversial for people cuz a
lot of people and I agree have the
experience of um as they respect
themselves more they they just don't
care about other people not respecting
themselves it's true that I would say
that's a little further Downstream but
usually what what you see as you
develop self-respect and and how does
self-respect get developed I think my
experience is primarily through the kind
of work that we're talking about about
where Where You Meet headon In your
experience the depth of complexity that
comes with your humanness and you keep
showing yourself over and over that
you're willing to meet that honestly and
work through the noise and try to parse
the soul from the ego and wisdom from
the anxiety and only you can see just
how complex and difficult that is when
you do that day after day after day like
the natural byproduct of that is one
self-trust because you know that you're
listening on the deepest level and no
one can tell you otherwise and two
self-respect because you know how hard
it is to do that work and how many
people are basically inviting you to
abandon yourself in service of their
ideas of what you should be doing so
that's how we start to get this
self-respect
and my experience is as that gets
developed more and more it it's like it
has this purifying effect in the system
and you start to see how much self uh
lack of respect you've tolerated from
other people because you haven't
actually known what respect feels like
because you're not giving it to yourself
so as you give it to yourself you're
then aware of like okay what's the
absence of this and you see it when
other people are are doing it and it's
just like whoa how have you been in my
life for so long if you treat me this
way and or like how have we allowed this
Dynamic to unfold like this and that's
where you start to put up boundaries or
in other ways you you can get to a point
where it's just like you see their pain
at the root of um of whatever they're
saying to you the way they're
disrespecting you and in that way it
might come compassion might come from
that but I want to make a point about
that which is that a lot of people think
like once you start you're spiritual or
you're mindful that you should jump
right to that point uh and just be
compassionate and I would just caution
against performing that compassion
if the thing that is most prevalent for
you is like putting up a boundary and
it's just like hey don't talk to me like
that uh even if there's some anger there
like
like make there's a role for making
space for that first in your system to
play out the energy of that and then and
you can you can have compassion in the
background but if you go a little too
much into like I know everyone's
suffering and it's just their pain
they're causing me just because of their
pain you again you can miss something
you can get out of sequence with the
process and what first might need to
arise is like hey the most alive thing
for me right now is that like this isn't
working I I I don't like that you're
talking to me in this way and that
doesn't always come out super clean as
nice as it would be for that to come out
super clean it it sometimes doesn't and
I have a lot of space for messiness and
yeah sure learn good communication
strategies they're they're definitely
important but make space for the
dimensions of your humanness do you
believe
that we can
only treat someone to the level that we
treat ourselves I do believe there's an
energetic truth to that as well this is
another one that tends to get some push
back it's like similar to you're only
able to love someone as much as you're
able to love yourself I think they there
is a reality where you know a lot of
people who struggle with self- Lov can
deeply care about and and tend to
another person um and this is why in
certain meditation practices where
you're cultivating loving kindness you
might first start with a puppy or your
child or someone for whom it feels
easier to feel love and then you turn it
toward
yourself but there the anyone who's also
walked this journey deeply and open
their own heart to themselves will see
that there is another level of what
you're able to offer another person like
how you're able to hold them in the
depth of their complexity in like a true
unconditional way that only really
presents itself when you've done that
work
internally and and it's it's just
because it's not really about you versus
another person it's just about like the
heart's capacity to
hold complexity and and pain and
suffering and hatred across the board
and so if it's stuck anywhere here it
can become a little more mental when
it's applied to another person rather
than like a fully embodied pure openness
that that fully embodied pure open heart
space like when it's it it has space for
for everything um and so the the
resonance the frequency of love in that
way is all enveloping yeah and it almost
feel it feels very it's almost like when
it gets to that point I'm just thinking
of people I my life like they don't even
have to do anything like there's a
there's an embodiment to the reality of
their care like the the realness of
their care it's just sort of sometimes
presence is already
enough and again I keep hammering these
points home uh of sometimes the journey
almost always no always the Journey of
getting to that open heart space is
preceded by not being in that heart
space it's preceded by anger sadness
grief confusion hating people hating
yourself and so if the the whole journey
of this opening is just like you stay
with exactly what's in front of you you
stay in sequence with exactly what's in
front of you you meet it as honestly and
as open and compassionate Ely as you can
and then you trust what unfolds from
there that is just like the step by step
by step
forever and anything else uh just easily
it becomes performed spirituality it
becomes I should be I should be kind I
should be heart opening and and then
you're missing what's actually here what
needs to First be touched it seems like
a good ending I was going to ask you
what you feel like is the most
lifechanging skill or trait that you
have cultivated I don't know if that's
it or not um but feel free to share if
you have something that's different
otherwise that was beautiful yeah it it
would be it it would be that it's for me
it it just you know what my time in
Burma did in in the monastery there
which kind of like kicked off my
spiritual journey is it developed a deep
companionship with myself I say the
biggest thing I got out of that
experience was becoming my own best
friend and then as I brought that into
the world where things were way Messier
and more complicated and so much harder
being in a relationship they always say
it's so easy to be a monk on the hill
that has no problems or like it's just
simple take the monk into the real world
and that's the challenge and that's been
my experience dead on and and so with
that companionship in the real world
yeah this bigger thing is just a
continued recognition of one it is all
super complex so cut yourself some slack
Corey
to the complexity is not an excuse to
abandon yourself or abandon
responsibility in relationship to it and
three like just keep showing up as
honestly and as sincerely as you can and
and if you can do that then what you
literally there's nothing else you can
ask of yourself because you're just
showing up with with an open heart and
with as much curiosity and humility as
you can and if you're doing that I just
anyone who's doing that I I give a deep
bow to
you thank you that was wonderful so
beautiful so deep and so enlightening
and inspiring and as as your writing is
just the same as your words super clear
and digestible and that's all I ever
hope with this show is that there's
somebody and they go oh like that makes
sense and you do a really good job of
that so thank you thanks
Dan thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more